[Music]
q4 of this year is going to be insane
shocktober when you hold up for when
you're playing football fourth quarter
fourth quarter in the fourth quarter
fourth quarter
yeah they had us the first half i'm not
gonna lie fourth quarter baby they had
us the whole game but it's all about the
fourth quarter fourth quarter fourth
quarterback hold it up this is your time
their time
is done
the chairman of the federal reserve
explicitly saying no intention to ban
bitcoin obviously bitcoin is going wild
on the internet el salvador has started
to mine bitcoin using energy from
volcano the apex predator the financial
markets is ready to roll you play to win
the game
hello you play to win the game going to
the fourth quarter of the football game
but they are who we thought they were
and we let them on the hook we can fight
our way back
into the light
we can climb out of hell we will not go
quietly into the night
and remember what got you here focus on
the fundamentals we've gone over time
and time again we can't be consumed by
our petty differences anymore
[Music]
we will be united in our common interest
we have won every single game we have
played until now
so this team
is perfect
we'll give us a little four figures in
the air for the fourth quarter
how we gonna finish it how are we gonna
close it out fourth quarter
[Music]
good morning good morning good morning
welcome back to the best business show
why is it the best because we said so
this is the show that my brothers and i
wish that we had when we were learning
about business investing in finance i am
here with two of my brothers joe and
john how do you know their names are joe
and john pretty simple their names are
on the back of their chairs they are
ready to go this weekend we had lots of
fun bitcoin continuing to just explode
upwards and let the world know why the
best store of value ever
is ready to rumble before we get into
that we've got two important operational
things the first we are already at 272
likes every 500 likes we get today we'll
be giving out bitcoin but there is no
set amount sometimes we might give out a
little sometimes we might give out a lot
you smash the like button for the free
content that's right the content is free
the entry fee is all you do is you press
that thumbs up button and every time we
cross over 500 more likes we'll give
away lots of free stuff i believe that
we sent somebody to an nfl game this
weekend correct yeah i'm waiting for the
photo okay so we should be getting photo
proof of that we've also got air pods
somebody got a pair of jeans jordan's at
the office somebody is wearing a pair of
jordans and lots and lots of folks got
bitcoin which continues to appreciate we
are working our way through all of you
on top of that we have sofi sofi.com the
best business show needs the best
partner and sofi has you covered
remember if you have student loans go
and get your student loans refinanced
they have very very low rates go to
sofi.com
and you can sign up there on top of that
we have the diamond hands club here's
how it works if you create a sofa
account so fi.com pomp you deposit two
thousand dollars into the account we
will be holding on
thursday night we will be holding a q a
where you'll get to go into a zoom with
me and my brothers and we will go ahead
and answer whatever questions you have
about investing business etc so let's
get after it go to software.compomp and
make sure you have that account created
and funded by 8 p.m eastern tonight john
well john and i also got haircuts oh
so did i oh yeah but you can't because
you can't see mine because mine's just
normal all right so ours look good
though big news we already passed 500
likes we're gonna get this show cracking
just kidding i was gonna be serious
today i'm not gonna be serious we're
gonna have fun today
uh first 500 likes here's how we're
gonna do this we're gonna give a hundred
dollars a bitcoin right now live on the
show all you have to do to get started
is just drop your twitter handle into
the chat john's gonna pick one person
let's go right now one two three press
the like button let's start warming up
episode
68 ready to rock and roll drop your
twitter account into the chat john's
going to pick one person they're going
to get 100 of bitcoin right now john who
you got john's got all the power today
uh
marcel starbucks has got some marco ass
coffee
who
that's what we do here you come here to
learn laugh and earn what's up joe
that's an interesting comment you make
about starbucks starbucks is straight
ass we go we're going we're going to be
drinking different coffees soon
i got something in the world i got
something in the works joe's trying to
get coffee sponsorships and i'm out here
drinking this trash coffee it's all
right whatever it's not that bad it's
not that bad i've been drinking i've
been trying out a new coffee and it is
top tier i'll tell you all we're gonna
break an all-time high bitcoin price
while we're on the show i'll tell
everyone soon all right let's go keep
smashing the like button we cost over a
thousand likes we'll give out more
bitcoin let's get into it as we start
the week let's take a look at bitcoin
price bitcoin at around 62 000
up about 1.4
or so s smp gold silver euro yen rendon
b and oil all trash assets in comparison
because when fiscal monetary policy is
out of control people need a store of
value that protects their purchasing
power and that is exactly what we're
watching happen with bitcoin if we go
ahead and we look at the individual
stats of the network 1.16
trillion dollar market cap very very
high and growing the inflation rate 1.78
there's 89
of the supply that is in circulation
about 10 billion dollars was settled on
chain in the last 24 hours one of my
favorite statistics is what is that
mining reward value the bitcoin miners
were paid 56.2 million dollars over the
last 24 hours to secure the network the
bitcoin network is the most
decentralized secure
largest most powerful computer network
in the world and that 56 million dollars
getting paid out to the miners is a big
part of it we are now about four to five
percent off of the all-time high
all-time highs around 64
800 or so and my guess is that we are
going to break that shortly
is it going to happen during the show is
it going to happen tomorrow it's going
to happen this week we will find out if
we go ahead and we look at the return on
investment with bitcoin you can see that
it's up 418 percent over the last year
or so what's very interesting is right
around this point
four years ago people are now up about a
thousand percent depending on when we
screenshot this exactly and so if you
had bought bitcoin on this day in 2017's
bull market and you held it and wrote it
through that 80 plus percent drawdown
and all the volatility along the way you
now would be up about 1 000
or 10x if you bought gold last year
you've literally lost 7 on a nominal
basis and you are down double digits on
a real return basis if we then go ahead
and we look at bitcoin versus the other
select indexes and assets you can see
that bitcoin is compound annual growth
rate that's cagr right there compound
annual growth rate over the last decade
has been 170
absolute astronomical performance for
the digital currency now when we start
to look at these statistics most of this
is looking backwards but what is very
interesting is there are tons of signs
that suggest that bitcoin is about to go
parabolic now what do i mean by that you
can look at the actual market structure
you can look at the on-chain metrics and
ask yourself what is this setting up for
if we first look at the actual number of
bitcoin that are on exchanges we can see
that from 2012 or so the number of
bitcoin on exchanges has drastically
dropped that's that yellow line that's
falling from the sky we then have kind
of oscillated there and continued to
remain at very low levels for quite a
while but what you can see is that since
september or so
or i'm sorry since september you can see
that we've been down here around these
all-time lows now over the weekend we
saw a slight drop right there at the end
you can see that slight drop in the
actual number of bitcoin that are on
exchanges as you can see usually when
that occurs there is an increase in
price why if there's tons of bitcoin
sitting on exchanges it's very easy to
sell it it creates selling pressure on
the price but if people are going onto
exchanges they're buying bitcoin they
then take it off of the exchange and so
the number of bitcoin on exchanges or
the exchange balance is going down that
suggests that there is more long-term
holders and therefore increases in
demand lead to an increase in price and
so very positive to see that we are
remaining somewhere near those all-time
lows from when it comes to exchange
balance
on top of that this morning from
charles edwards we got this tweet that
suggested that the mvrv z score has
reclaimed three now for those that don't
know mvrv z score is essentially the
difference between the total market cap
and the realized market cap total market
cap simply takes the number of
outstanding bitcoin times the price per
bitcoin that's what you see in that 1.16
trillion dollar market cap but what the
realized cap is it looks at when was the
last time that this bitcoin actually
traded hands and what was the price at
that moment so if i last sold a bitcoin
let's say to joseph at one thousand
dollars that would count as one thousand
dollars towards the realized cap versus
the sixty two thousand dollars that it
would count towards the market cap and
so when you look at the difference
between the total market cap and the
realized market cap and then you divide
it by the standard deviation of the
market cap you can score it what we know
is that when we cross over three
it usually leads to a drastic increase
in price and we just reclaimed that
three there and so when we see these
types of movements there usually ends up
being a market structure that has a very
bullish story behind it but last but not
least dylan leclair coming out and
showing that the long-term holders are
still in accumulation mode even though
85 of bitcoin has not moved in the last
90 days long-term holders are still
buying more and he said that typically
we see these during bear markets or
consolidation periods but instead we are
watching this happen as bitcoin's price
has doubled over the last couple of
months from thirty thousand now up over
sixty thousand dollars so to see those
long-term holders continuing to
accumulate into price strength like this
is very very bullish and so when we
start to look at what is actually
occurring in the market and because of
the on-chain metrics and that open
transparent ledger that bitcoin provides
we can see that not only has bitcoin
been very strong over the last 10 years
over the last year but also the market
structure and the setup is very
interesting now on top of that we've got
the bitcoin etf coming we're going to
talk about that later in the show but
also right before the show started
interactive brokers announced that they
are going to allow for registered
investment advisors rias think of these
as more financial advisors they are
going to allow them now to buy bitcoin
and cryptocurrencies via their
traditional platform
what this does is it allows for every
registered investment advisor in the
united states using that interactive
broker's platform to start to give their
clients exposure john how many different
rias are there in the country and do we
know how much assets they have yeah it's
just under 14 000 like 13 500 and then
was it the aum of them is 110 trillion
in
like 61 million clients so if we talk
about 65 million clients with a hundred
plus trillion dollars in assets that are
managed by about 14 000 registered
investment
advisors interactive brokers just opened
the floodgates and said you now have the
opportunity to get those assets that 110
trillion dollars or so into the bitcoin
or cryptocurrency market if those
advisors choose to simply just move one
percent about 1.1 trillion dollars into
bitcoin that would be double the market
cap of the asset today so we would go
from the 1.1 trillion we already have
plus 1.1 trillion from the rias and
therefore you have a 2.2 trillion dollar
market cap the amount of wealth that is
held by riaa's is absolutely insane and
when we look at the market structure the
fact that it's a highly illiquid asset
with 85 percent not having moved in the
last 90 days and then the mvrv z score
going over three
it becomes a very very explosive
situation
you have a similar situation to what you
had back in 2020 you've got supply that
nobody wants to sell but you have
increasing demand not only do you have
increasing demand because of the macro
environment and sustained levels of over
five percent inflation but you also have
increased access points people who have
had high demand for the asset but
they've struggled to get exposure
previously now they can use etfs now
they can also use the interactive
broker's platform from rias and you put
all that demand into an illiquid supply
and it is likely to lead to a very high
price increase now history does not mean
that that is a signal for what's going
to happen in the future there's risk
with all of this but i like to see this
type of market structure this type of
increasing demand with this type of
illiquid asset and so just as we've been
talking about four weeks now q4
historically has turned out to be very
positive in bull markets for bitcoin's
asset but
when you start to add in all of these
other factors not only having the q4
situation but also increased assets and
the illiquid supply my guess is that we
are going to see absolute rocket fuel
point poured on one of the best
performing assets in the world what do
you guys think i think uh there's two
things right so one is gold when you
look at gold right it's just failed
we're i was looking at the countries
earlier there's a bunch of countries
that have over four percent inflation
there's spain germany canada india the
us obviously is over five uh mexico
russia brazil large large large
countries are all experiencing uh really
aggressive rates of inflation right so
gold is traditionally seen as that hedge
against inflation or that asset that
people would move capital in to protect
their wealth it's completely failed
right it's down year over year as we've
seen those heightened levels of
inflation so i think the gold story uh
has changed drastically and bitcoin is
taking over and has has really taken
over as that uh that store of value and
i think you know mark cuban admitted it
the other day it's the best store value
in the world right it's digital it's
decentralized etc so i think uh bitcoin
has proven that that's the case the
second thing i would say is like
when we talk about kind of all the
things that are happening in the market
now it really is kind of the perfect uh
convergence of things for bitcoin's
price to appreciate right so you talked
about uh you know almost nearly 90 of
the supply that's ever going to exist of
bitcoin uh is currently in circulation
and then out of that 90 80 to 85 percent
of that is being held by people who
aren't willing to sell it right anyone
who's held it for three months or longer
so there's a supply squeeze happening at
the same time that you know the the
futures etf is one thing i don't think i
think we all agree that's probably not
the biggest deal uh but it opens the
doors and shows that regulators are
willing to approve a spot etf
potentially right which could bring a
bunch of assets in interactive brokers
no uh
news corporations are adding to their
balance sheet there's a bunch of kind of
different things that i think are
setting up for us to drastically
increase the price again john what do
you think perfectly said it's a perfect
storm for bitcoin right now i think
right so bitcoin's up what over 400 over
the last year s p 500 over the last 10
years is up 250
those are ridiculous numbers right and
just seeing that i don't think these
returns will last for forever right at
some point in time it kind of levels off
and plateaus a little bit but get the
returns while you can now why it's a
growing asset um in this kind of uh in
this growth phase of bitcoin right now
i'm using as a store of value and uh i
hope other people are as well no matter
how much bitcoin you have you never have
enough is that how you feel that's right
the interactive especially right now is
great for bitcoin well so again if we if
you just summarize this in in very short
order right you have a highly illiquid
asset that the macro environment is
forcing investors to go by you then open
up etfs both with the futures based etf
that's gonna start trading tomorrow you
also have grayscale announcing that
they're going to put in the application
to convert the bitcoin trust the gbtc
into a bitcoin etf a spot market etf
then you also have interactive brokers
on top of that you have more and more
institutions every day announcing that
they're buying it they're giving access
to their clients also i think that we're
going into earnings season it would
shock me if we don't get one or two
large corporations and say hey we've
started to add that to our balance sheet
as well and so not only is it a perfect
storm but i think to me what's more
interesting is not just market structure
but it's when you add all these factors
up we're not talking about something
that if it goes up is going to go up 10
or 20 percent we're talking about
something that has a parabolic aspect to
it right 10 to 20 in a day
and again i always am careful to say
like look anything can happen in the
future there could be an external
catastrophic event how many people saw
global pandemic coming in 2020 like
there's all this risk so you got to
understand what what uh the risks are
but if you're simply just looking at
market structure and understanding that
you have an illiquid supply with
increasing demand and you either believe
in supply demand economics or you don't
like that's the part to me that's
absolutely nuts is when we go and we see
all these economists talking about it
like when they go and they teach their
economics 101 course they teach supply
demand right and so if we have a fixed
supply asset demand increases price has
to go up but literally these economists
will sit there and say like oh no price
is going to go down and you're like why
and they're like well and they come up
with some cockamamie reason why but if
you just say hey listen it's a fixed
supply asset and do you believe demand's
going to go up or down and they say well
people may continue to buy it okay then
price has to go up that's the funniest
part to me is because typically they'll
admit and they'll agree that demand will
continue to increase over time right and
adoption will continue to increase so
the whole thing that it's going to go
down or go to zero or all this stuff is
just it's uh intellectually dishonest
almost right like they understand supply
and demand and they're willing to admit
that demand will continue to increase so
when you break it down very simply the
price has to go up completely agree bam
we just hit over 1 000 likes on the
video you know what that means we're
gonna give out 200 of bitcoin right now
what i want you to do is i want you in
the chat tell us what did you do this
weekend leave your twitter account what
did you do this weekend leave your
twitter account when you come here free
content you get to learn but the entry
fee you just gotta like the video smash
the like button as we keep growing the
number of likes on the video we'll keep
giving out more and more bitcoin what
did you do this weekend leave your
twitter account joe's gonna pick one
person and they're gonna get 200 of
bitcoin right here on the spot as we
are knocking on the doorstep of the
all-time high joe who you got
hang on they got it oh joe joe joe likes
to let it marry i like to give him i
like to give everyone a chance
they don't have good wi-fi they need the
money yeah
i like to give him a chance
joe doesn't like to just show up to the
kitchen and eat he's the type of guy who
like three days before he's like we're
gonna make some brisket i'm gonna go get
him a marinated and i'm gonna let it
cook overnight are you good yeah i'm
good how does it feel how does it feel
that you spent all night coming with
that joke and it didn't hit that wasn't
a joke that was that was a positive he's
sad
you're a long-term thinker you're a
long-term pick by the way i want
everyone to know ranger bit me over the
weekend
ranger didn't he's a puppy if anyone
knows anything about puppies they uh i
believe it's called teething and he
bites things with toys well give him a
gift
you put your arm there and he bit your
arm yeah that's what you get okay all
right and then you put them on instagram
for clout so we're suggesting we're
clear just so we're clear joe's dog bit
me this weekend uh that's what i want
him to do somebody said put ranger down
don't say that though and that person
all right come on who do you got let's
go we're giving out 200 bitcoin right
here on the spot joe let's go
uh all right first winner got a hundred
bucks first winner got a hundred bucks
make sure it's in the spreadsheet so
that that's
or do you want the twitter or the
username the username
alien babies podcast
[Laughter]
he worked on his resume this weekend oh
nice all right you got the twitter
account alien babies podcast you went to
where else are you going to come and get
alien babies podcast winning bitcoin for
free nowhere only on this show keep
smashing the like button we're almost at
1.5 k actually you know what i'll give
out another 200 of bitcoin right now if
we cross over 1.5 k ready one two three
smash the like button once we cross 1.5
k we'll give out another 200 bitcoin
boom
on friday jack dorsey and square
announcing that they have intentions to
potentially go into bitcoin mining now
we are going to go through each one of
these tweets because this is a big big
deal square is obviously started in the
hardware business with the dongle that
you used to be able to swipe using your
smartphone but now they have become one
of the largest fintech companies in the
world it's a 115 billion dollar market
cap company and we all know that jack
dorsey is very bullish on bitcoin
historically square has done a number of
different things in the industry they
one have put bitcoin on their balance
sheet two they have allowed users of
cash app to go ahead and purchase
bitcoin very easily
three is they announced intentions to do
an open source hardware bitcoin wallet
and then four is that at one point they
also have announced that they are
interested in quote an open developer
platform with the sole goal of making it
easy to create non-custodial
permissionless and decentralized
financial services focused on bitcoin so
obviously square is making a very big
play here now around the mining hardware
jack started out and he said square is
considering building a bitcoin mining
system based on custom silicone and open
source for individuals and businesses
worldwide if we do this we'd follow our
hardware wallet model build in the open
in collaboration with the community
first some thoughts and questions he
then goes on to say mining needs to be
more distributed the core job of a miner
is to securely settle transactions
without the need for trusted third
parties this is critical well after the
last bitcoin is mined the more
decentralized this is the more resilient
the bitcoin network becomes true
second mining needs to be more efficient
driving towards clean and efficient
energy use is great for bitcoin's
economics impact and scalability energy
is a system level problem that requires
innovation in silicon software and
integration what are the largest
opportunities here he then goes on with
three silicone design is concentrated
into a few companies this means supply
is likely overly constrained silicon
development is very expensive requires
long-term investment and is best coupled
tightly with software and system design
why aren't more companies doing this
work
four he then says is there isn't enough
focus on vertical integration
considering hardware software
productization and distribution requires
accountability for delivering to an end
customer versus improving a single
technology in the chain does seeing this
as a single system improve accessibility
fifth one mining isn't accessible to
everyone bitcoin mining should be as
easy as plugging a rig into a power
source there isn't enough incentive
today for individuals to overcome the
complexity of running a miner for
themselves one of the biggest barriers
for people running miners and then
lastly our team led by jessie deroche
i'm going to mess it up we'll start the
deep technical investigation required to
take on this project we'd love your
thoughts ideas concerns and
collaboration should we do it why or why
not we'll update this thread as we make
our decisions and now over to jesse when
i saw this there was two main things
that immediately jumped to mind one
square is building the largest bitcoin
company in the world
it's a 115 billion dollar business today
and we are slowly watching the evolution
from a fintech to a bitcoin company when
you start to look at everything again
from putting it on the balance sheet to
allowing cash app users to buy bitcoin
to creating an open source hardware
wallet to now getting into the
decentralized financial services around
bitcoin and mining you can see that if
jack dorsey pulls this off the 115
billion dollar company would be going
after a multi-trillion dollar
opportunity pretty incredible now these
problems are really really difficult
they require not only systems design
thinking they also require first
principles thinking and they require the
fortitude and the ability to think long
term
you can't simply just wake up one day
and say you know what we are going to
get into the silicone chip game that's a
very difficult difficult business to be
in it requires tons of different skills
that square may not have internally
today whether it's the expertise the
experience or frankly the
uh the back
time that they've spent in investing the
capital and the design this is the real
deal now if they would be successful
over the coming years they would
essentially be building a brand new
ecosystem of
products and services around bitcoin i
ultimately think that building it in an
open with collaboration with the
community is the right move i ultimately
think open sourcing as much of it as
possible is the right mood and i think
that it is really interesting to see a
company that has a massive balance sheet
that has that 115 billion dollar market
cap doing this will serve as an example
as to why more publicly traded companies
should start to participate in the
ecosystem as well
one of the ideas that i continue to go
back to is the idea of plugging in to
the bitcoin system what i mean by that
is if you're an investor you can plug
your capital into the bitcoin system if
you are a hardware manufacturer or you
have energy you can plug into the
bitcoin system you can begin mining if
you are a company you can start to do
things in the bitcoin ecosystem you can
plug into the bitcoin network every time
somebody chooses to take an asset that
they have whether it's capital whether
it's services or whether it's something
else and plug into the bitcoin network
they are essentially hiring millions of
people around the world to join their
team whether it is simply by cheering
for their success and saying hey you
believe in the same things i believe in
we're all on team bitcoin we are going
to do our best to help you be successful
or it is something much much more like
using the technology where there's
millions of developers or holders or
people developing various products and
services around the technology you are
hiring the bitcoin community when you
plug into the system one of my favorite
examples is tahini's restaurant in
canada they have nothing to do with
bitcoin but they love bitcoin they
plugged into the system and now people
will go out of their way to come visit
the restaurant they've built a national
brand in the united states and even some
would argue a global brand simply
because they plugged into the system no
one would have thought that a restaurant
could plug into the system but now when
you take that idea and you say square
100 plus billion dollar fintech company
plugging into the bitcoin network it is
likely to provide a massive opportunity
that most people are drastically
underestimating so what do we think
about square getting into the mining
business potentially but doing it from
going
uh and recreating silicone and and uh
really producing silicone chips all the
way on up to the actual mining systems
themselves yeah i mean if they're able
to do this on uh like give individuals
the ability to do it for a cheaper and
kind of on a larger scale i think it's
super impactful right for as much as uh
you know bitcoin helps with personal uh
economic freedom with decentralization
with kind of all these things this can
democratize the process even more and i
think traditionally when you think of
bitcoin mining you think of these large
facilities that are temperature
controlled and have access to uh you
know cheap power or cheap energy and
they can um that they're using asics
that are tens of thousands if not
hundreds of thousands of dollars and you
don't necessarily think about kind of
the common average person so i think
this gives those people more access and
i think it's a good and important thing
and the one thing i really like about it
is that you know he's open uh similar to
how square has done in the past he's
gonna he's open and committed to doing
this in public
john what do you think yeah dorsey
started recently mining with compass
mining right so he either really liked
the rewards or hated the process that um
was in place and wants to build his own
he's building one of the largest bitcoin
companies uh so for the fact that he can
do the whole process now right so
earlier this year he started working on
the bitcoin hardware wallet super
interesting jesse the guy who's running
this team also was heading uh the
bitcoin hardware wallets too and look
payments mining wallets he's getting the
whole ecosystem of bitcoin and bringing
it all together into square uh makes a
lot of sense be interested to see what
he does
the piece to me um that is fascinating
is that they not only are going after
one hard problem they're going after
many hard problems
and it feels like there's a little bit
of a hub and spoke model here where
square is saying okay we have now agreed
that bitcoin is going to be a crucial
part of the financial system moving
forward we as a financial services
business want to be the leader in this
space and so what we're going to do is
we're going to look at the entire
ecosystem and say what are the key
pieces of infrastructure and the key
products and services that need to be
created around this asset to usher it to
kind of global adoption and then what
we're going to do is we're basically
going to take each one of those and
we're going to put a team and resources
behind it to go and build so we're going
to go and we're going to do the hardware
wall we're going to go and do mining
we're going to go and do the uh
decentralized financial services we're
going to go and actually put on our
balance sheet etc but
everyone is focused in some weird way on
oh square likes bitcoin i think that
there's nuance in the things they're
trying to do have very very long-term
investment similar to when amazon
started to do things like aws everyone's
like hey what are you guys doing you
sell things on the internet why are you
getting into the data center business
now aws is an absolute monster of a
business my guess is that what we're
watching square do is replicate the
amazon strategy and look at all of the
different components of the business and
say we want to make a multi-year or
multi-decade investment in that area and
if we really dedicate the next 20 30
years to this we can become the largest
bitcoin company in the world but
understand that it's not just about a
capitalistic view and an extractive view
of how do we
sell things to the community and make
money instead what we can do is we can
empower this community through open
source software and kind of align
yourself with the ethos and continue to
usher this asset to global adoption if
they make bitcoin successful square will
be very very successful and i think
that's part of the beauty is you align
the incentives here where it's not so
much pitting the customers against the
company instead what you're doing is now
the company understands let's make these
customers successful let's make this
asset successful and therefore we'll
gain value from doing that yeah and i
also think uh i agree with all of that
and i think one of the things that's
interesting is watching jack
basically simultaneously go between now
and the future right when you when you
think of square they have cash app they
obviously have a bunch of payment
software uh programs they have a bunch
of merchants they just bought in uh a
buy now pay later company so they're
they're doing a really good job at teams
of kind of giving customers what they
need today and for the foreseeable
future but then he's also doing all
these things with bitcoin uh and other
digital assets that he can say hey look
we're building something for the future
and you can you know it's always
interesting to see uh whether it's a
current ceo or kind of just a great
entrepreneur people you know tangle that
line of like hey we need to figure out
what's going on but we also don't want
to be disrupted and taken over and
forgotten a day from a day from now
right so i think uh he's proven that
that's what he's focused on and i think
bitcoin is one of those things that he's
putting a large amount of his time
effort uh and frankly money into and his
reputation and saying hey look this is
what i see being a big part of the
future of not everyone of not only
everyone uh globally but specifically my
company square jack's the perfect person
to lead this yeah i agree and i think
that uh not only does he go and execute
on all of that he again he also is
serving as an example right if you're
sitting there in your financial services
business and you see what he's doing it
forces you to have the conversation
should we be getting in that game right
and you may choose to opt out or not
participate but he's forcing that
conversation now and he's not only doing
it with the legacy organizations he's
also doing it with more of these like
fintechs so if you're sitting there and
you run like a traditional fintech and
it's funny to say traditional fintech
but if you basically thought you were
competing with the banks now all of a
sudden you turn around you're like wait
a minute am i actually competing with
bitcoin and with square and these
organizations and i think what those
fintechs are gonna realize is uh they
used to believe that you started out you
moved as fast as you could and then you
ultimately went after the legacy
businesses to try to gain legitimacy and
what square's done really really well is
square is basically saying hey we have
our core business but this new world
we're not trying to replicate what's
going on in the old world we want to be
the leader the pioneer in the new world
and this new thing is not understood
very well by the legacy players and
therefore we don't have a lot of
competition and i wouldn't be surprised
to see some of these really well-funded
fintech businesses where the founders
actually own bitcoin they're paying
attention to the asset all their friends
are leaving their their uh businesses
and they're going they're working in the
industry they don't start to say to
themselves hey i got 250 people who work
for me i'm well funded i got tier one uh
venture capitalist we're in the
financial services industry we should
start to play in this game too and they
start to slowly migrate over and
incorporate various assets incorporate
various uh products and services and
then they basically are replicating what
square's doing in the public market they
just do it in the private market and you
know again it goes back to bitcoin is
good for business whether you're
publicly traded privately traded with
your uh asset manager a for-profit
business whether you're an individual if
bitcoin is good for business eventually
everyone capitulates and the incentives
take over i would say that's also an
interesting point when it comes to kind
of built what you're building right and
talent is obviously a huge part of that
the people that you recruit today are
building the products that you're gonna
kind of roll out two three five ten
years from now right so what do young
people want to do what do successful
smart young people want to do everyone i
know is interested in crypto right
whether it's bitcoin or another asset
they're all interested in crypto and
they want to build products and services
centered on that so i think uh when it
comes to legacy banks for someone like
square or legacy institutions or someone
like square i think the argument really
is like from a talent standpoint where
are you going to go join it's much more
likely you're going to go join square
than one of these other legacy banks or
institutions uh that have shown not only
are they slower to adapt and make
changes to this but some of them are not
even willing to do it right so when you
talk about being well funded and all
this other stuff it all makes a
difference but i think at the end of the
day uh the talent that that square is
able to recruit will make a big
difference also the piece to me that's
fascinating is you have all these
corporate uh
balance sheets that have literally you
know 100 trillion dollars or whatever
sitting on the corporate uh balance
sheets as well and uh or maybe not a
hundred trillion hundred billion or
whatever the number is uh that's all
sitting on these corporate balance
sheets and they're sitting there and
they're taking a five percent inflation
on the chin
right if you're sitting there as the cfo
and you're literally experiencing five
plus percent cpi and you're also forced
with uh supply chain constraints and
your labor costs are going up like
you're getting in a bad situation
historically what they would do is to
offset inflation they would go and they
would buy bonds but the bond market or
the treasury market is getting decimated
as well you literally go and you buy a
bond or a treasury and you're guaranteed
to lose money it's a negative real rate
a real return
asset if you buy it inflation is eating
not only the return but it's actually
forcing you to lose purchasing power and
so it's not a good safe haven and so as
these corporations start to wake up and
say wait a second we can't do that okay
what's another inflation hedge asset oh
let's go buy gold oh wait a second
gold's down seven percent over the last
12 months i would have lost double digit
percentage if i would have bought gold
from a real return basis they ultimately
all start to turn and say what is this
bitcoin thing why is it that paul tudor
jones and stanley drucken miller and all
of these really successful wall street
hedge funds are starting to get in the
game why is it that a nation made it
legal tender why is it that square and
tesla and microstrategy all have put it
on their balance sheet eventually they
start to realize we are going to lose an
immense amount of value for our
shareholders and i would argue that
publicly traded companies have a
fiduciary duty to their shareholders to
put bitcoin on the balance sheet at this
point if you do not put bitcoin on the
balance sheet you are violating your
fiduciary duty because you are sitting
in cash or cash equivalents that are
getting decimated by persistent high
levels of inflation and if you do not
protect that cash and you knowingly are
letting it melt away like an ice cube
then in my opinion you are violating
your fiduciary duty because you know
that you're losing money and you're
doing it intentionally when there is
another option now it doesn't mean that
you should go take a hundred percent of
the balance sheet and go put it in but
if you simply were to hedge for example
the asset is up over 400 in the last
year if last year
you had taken two percent of your
balance sheet and you would put it into
bitcoin and then you got that 400
percent uh appreciation you would have
protected your entire balance sheet from
inflation your return on that two
percent allocation would have outweighed
the five plus percent decrease in your
purchasing power of the cash so you
don't have to put a lot but you do have
to start to use a small portion of the
balance sheet to hedge over inflation
again are we gonna see people do it
probably not do i think they should
absolutely i also think that
shareholders are going to start
demanding it and they're going to start
saying we have billions of dollars tens
of goods in some cases 100 plus billion
dollars sitting on a balance sheet why
is it sitting in cash and cash
equivalents why are we letting it get
eaten away by inflation instead of
trying to protect it john you disagree i
don't think that it is their duty to put
bitcoin on their balance sheet i think
it is their duty to research the asset
and figure out whether they want to
proceed in any manner
so i agree that it is their duty to go
and research it but once you look at the
facts and say okay i have cash and cash
equivalents they're getting decimated by
inflation i have another asset that's
been the best performing inflation hedge
asset in the world for over a decade
you can't but history is not obviously
again
true but when you start to actually
understand the asset when you do the
research and you look at those two
assets and you say i am going to put 100
percent of my balance sheet in cash and
cash equivalents you're overexposed you
have too much concentration in dollars
and dollar equivalents instead what you
should do is you should diversify it's
actually a risk management strategy it
is not about how do i get the highest
return if you want the highest return
you can go play the lottery what i'm
talking about is risk management and so
instead of taking a material percent
take one or two percent they put it into
bitcoin they use that bitcoin as a hedge
as uh chamath palpatible called like a
schmuck insurance and you simply say if
i put it in bitcoin and bitcoin
continues to appreciate at the rate that
it has appreciated the last decade 170
compound annual growth rate i will
protect my entire balance sheet with a
very very small percentage investment
from my balance sheet that to me is what
now had went from a contrarian idea to
now must become the consensus on in the
public markets because anyone who's not
doing that is either asleep at the wheel
or complicit in watching the shareholder
value be eroded away by five plus
percent inflation we've even seen the us
government the white house et cetera all
come out and say they're all adjusting
their inflation expectations over the
next 12 months higher and higher they've
in some cases two to two and a half
times increased what they think
inflation is going to be in q4 all the
way to q4 of next year if everyone
around you is saying hey there's going
to be higher levels of inflation and you
do nothing then you are violating the
number one rule in life which is when
you get new information it's a sign of
intelligence to change your mind it's
fine to have thought over time to keep
cash and cash equivalents but if you
don't put bitcoin on the balance sheet
at this point you are complicit in
eroding your shareholders value so you
have to go and listen let's let's use a
real example right so we talked about it
on the show when it happened palantir in
early august they said we're going to
take 50 million off our balance sheet
that we had in cash and we're going to
diversify we're going to put it into
gold they bought physical gold bars so
not only did they buy the bars but then
they went and stored them at some
facility uh i believe in the northeast
and instead of buying bitcoin or
anything else they bought gold right so
gold since that period the last 75 days
is essentially flat bitcoin's up 55
percent
it's crazy in 75 days right so
granted right like who knows what's
going to happen in the future what might
happen uh etc but the idea that you're
going to put it in an asset like gold
that has underperformed everything else
in the market when structurally uh
there's been high inflation like all
these things are happening that gold
should be performing really well instead
of an asset like bitcoin that has
historically appreciated when you look
at things uh volatility adjusted ratios
like the sharpe ratio it's performed
much better than a bunch of different
assets including gold so 50 million
bucks in the grand scheme of their
balance sheet not a lot right
volunteer's a massive company uh but at
the end of the day they had better
options and they didn't take them uh and
now they're paying the price when it
comes to the return that they could have
expected
we just crossed over
1.5 k likes we're about to cross over
two on the count of three everyone press
the like button ready one two three
press the like button and we are going
to give away what we're gonna do 300 of
bitcoin now yep 300 of bitcoin okay so
wait what are we doing it goes up every
time no
is that one
i'll be broke but we gave away 100 then
200 now 300 that'd be 600 total so far
today we just crossed over 2 000. here's
what we're going to do in the chat what
i want you to leave is
do you agree or not agree that public
companies should all put bitcoin on
their balance sheet and leave your
twitter handle you have to leave your
twitter handle agree or disagree that
public companies should be putting
bitcoin on their balance sheet john's
gonna pick one person twitter handle
plus do you agree or not agree and we're
going to give 300 of bitcoin here live
to one person why the best business show
the only place where you can learn laugh
and earn people are sucking up to john
call them johnny jets
john
the video by the way i rewatched the
video of you on the motorcycle with the
merch you're cool on saturday morning i
watched that maybe a hundred times john
john had a hell of a weekend john by the
way i don't know if everyone here jenga
is a popular game right oh john
john is fire with the gym i'll have to
show it tomorrow on the thing but john
uh
for those who know what jenga is you
know you pull out the the slots or
whatever john there was one at the end
of the game where there was just one
piece of the django board left on the
bottom so everything's on very bottom
i had the only move it was essentially
when you get to the end and there's only
one move which is pull the last one out
john there's a video of it we'll get it
rips it out the whole thing falls down
stays perfectly intact john won the game
and john and john looks at everyone like
yeah no i think he went like this
all right i got a winner all right who
do you got vast v their name is wassie
the wasp
oh nice vast v nice
they agreed or disagreed they agreed
all right hey listen i agree with them
too i think that's exactly what's going
to end up happening all right
over the weekend
congrats vassy v you just won 300 bucks
will you just tell them give a little
speech john yeah come on we are giving
away money every single day on this show
congratulations let's not take this
lightly here it's no problem there's no
problem no problem
that's the whole speech yeah can we get
a cheers yeah we should start doing a
little cheers with coffee i'll bring my
ass coffee right here and then you guys
bring good coffee we'll give you uh
we'll give another speech if you say
igloo
[Music]
i've been dealing with these guys all
dawning i've been dealing with them all
morning one's got shoes on one tv dm me
all right let's go congrats over the
weekend i tweeted out a thread on a
great article in national affairs
national affairs has this article uh
which basically outlines exactly what is
happening in a macro economic situation
it outlines what is bitcoin and then it
argues why america has an opportunity in
front of itself to go ahead and embrace
bitcoin
through that thread mark cuban famous
billionaire the mavs owner and the shark
tank participant went ahead and
responded to the thread and at one point
i had said something like bitcoin
embodies the american ethos and mark
responded with
a tongue-in-cheek response that
essentially said yes the american ethos
obviously it you yell and scream at
everyone unless they agree with you and
that kicked off an absolute firestorm i
have no doubt that mark knew exactly
what he was doing by kicking the
hornet's nest because bitcoiners began
to bash him and attack him and call him
every name in the book and mark stood
there like an absolute goliath fighting
off everyone by himself
at some point we moved the conversation
from twitter into a twitter spaces and
in there mark started to share his
thoughts now what was fascinating to me
is that most people in the chat were
interested in attacking him or having
some sort of abrasive conversation
explaining to him why he's wrong on
things or telling him where he missed
the mark and if you go ahead and you
just search through twitter and search
mark cuban and bitcoin you'll see plenty
of people whether they were one of the
15 000 people that were listening live
or they got some sort of uh opinion
about it later and they're calling them
an idiot a fraud a [ __ ] and all these
other things but what's shocking to me
is mark cuban is a bitcoiner mark cuban
owns bitcoin mark cuban said on multiple
occasions both tweets and also live in
the chat of the twitter spaces
i believe bitcoin is the greatest store
of value that's why i own it
and so mark agrees with bitcoiners on
the global store value thesis he
believes not only that it is a store of
value he believes it is the best store
of value that's why he owns it now where
mark and the bitcoiners disagree is that
mark sees a low probability of bitcoin
becoming an absolute
global medium of exchange he doesn't say
that it's impossible he just says that
there's lots of challenges and obstacles
to get there and he thinks that the
probability is low now obviously most
bitcoiners think the probability is much
higher than mark does that's okay they
both see a path it's just what is the
probability for that path actually being
realized
and so i think what the most interesting
part of this was
is that mark cuban a billionaire
somebody who's widely respected for his
thoughts on technology who's built
multiple successful companies who
whether we like it or not
is one of the darlings of the media when
he says things the media writes it
people who are not in the investing
world or not in the technology world
they look up to mark and they want to
know his opinion on certain things they
see him on shark tank on abc
he is really important to get
educated on the asset and so rather than
attack people like this we should
actually be embracing them we should be
using this as an education opportunity
as an opportunity to recruit someone to
see the world that we see it and again
you got to listen to be able to do that
and so when i heard mark saying that he
thought bitcoin was the greatest store
of value on the market that made me
happy mark cuban's a bitcoiner there's
nothing wrong with that now
lots of people have problems because
mark also has talked about dogecoin or
he's talking about other assets and
that's okay there's no problem with that
again he explicitly said look i believe
x is gonna happen if it doesn't happen
i'll lose money that is what the free
market does and so we got to be careful
of is we can't simply just yell and
scream at people all the time and say
hey you're wrong you're a [ __ ] you're
an idiot you're a fraud you're a scam
that's not how the world works at some
point what we have to realize is that
rather than be abrasive the best path
sometimes is to listen it's to hear what
somebody is saying and to simply say you
know what here is where the common
ground is we both agree that bitcoin is
the greatest store of value in the
market amazing by the way you think that
there's a low probability that it could
become a medium of exchange well other
people think that there's a high
probability and therefore let us explain
to you why and then allow him to say i
agree or i disagree and here's why and
have a conversation about it now i fully
think that there's plenty of other
people like this that are going to come
into the market that are going to have
opinions some of them actually are going
to be very uneducated right one of the
things that i think uh the bitcoin
community gets right is that the critics
of bitcoin frankly aren't that
intelligent they're not that well
informed and we're lucky to have such
ridiculously
low
uh prepared
critics i love the fact that they show
up and they say things that were being
said back in 2012 that have been
disproved for almost a decade great they
sound like idiots
but
mark cuban and there's others
they actually are very well informed and
in many cases they're not actually a
critic what they're trying to do is have
a rational conversation say hey here's
what i believe this is why i own the
asset i actually see great value in it
but here's the challenges i see here's
the obstacles i see moving forward
sometimes those rational conversations
are really worth it right
yeah i listened to the uh the twitter
spaces you were up late past your
bedtime listen yeah
go ahead i put ranger to bed first and
then yeah uh no but i listened to the
conversation and i thought it was
interesting because first off
regardless of what your opinion is on on
his specific uh kind of overview of of
bitcoin or other cryptos or whatever you
have to respect the fact that he came in
the room with 15 000 people that didn't
like him right and we're gonna set to
argue against them and then second off i
think he was on the treadmill or
something which was pretty funny in its
own right uh but so i i certainly
respect the idea that he came in the
room ready to fight right and that's the
other point of it too is right like you
have to expect someone to be a little uh
when everyone's coming at them you have
to expect them to kind of give you a
little heat back and he certainly did
that but at the same time right like
he's made a lot of comments in the past
that he's contradicted himself he said
certain things about bitcoin that not
necessarily everyone agrees with uh so
there's certainly some history there as
to why people don't trust what he has to
say or trust his opinion or or find his
uh opinion to be uh
intelligent on it right i'd say so i
think there there's some concern there
but ultimately you're right in the
aspect of like he did agree on something
right he said bitcoin's the biggest the
best store value in the world he owns he
owns it uh he talked about dogecoin and
some other things but i think ultimately
he agrees on a lot of things the one
main point of contention that he pushed
back on was just seeing uh bitcoin as a
medium of exchange right and saying hey
look uh most of the bitcoiners believe
that we'll get to a point where there's
hundreds of millions if not billions of
people globally that have adopted
bitcoin are using it as a medium of
exchange mark doesn't think that we'll
get that right he just says that there's
better technology there's better uh kind
of projects out there that might get
there quicker or have an advantage in
doing it and he he made some good points
some points that people obviously didn't
agree with but ultimately i think these
are the conversations that whether you
agree with his points or not are good
and healthy debates right and the idea
that uh anyone who opposes your view
you're gonna kind of just [ __ ] on right
is not smart in my opinion i think you
need to be willing to hear other
people's takes that doesn't mean he's
right right you can you can take it uh
kind of step back and say hey look maybe
this is a good idea maybe it's not but
ultimately you don't want to become the
crowd that's always kind of giving
people a hard time uh for no reason so i
think
those debates are good a lot of people
seem to enjoy it there are 15 000 people
in the room uh and whether cuban ends up
being right or not on the global
adoption of bitcoin uh those are the
conversations that we should continue to
have you know just smart people kind of
all in the room talking about the the
future of money the other piece of this
i think is really important is that
bitcoin doesn't need anybody right
bitcoin doesn't need anybody on its side
it will be successful with or without
individual people it doesn't need me
doesn't mean you guys doesn't need any
of these companies right it doesn't need
a billionaire or a pleb literally
doesn't need anybody he doesn't care
about anybody he just continues to prove
block after block after block of
transactions but
that doesn't mean that we should go and
try to piss everybody off and and get
everyone uh to work against it right in
some way what i think you want to do is
you want to say hey we don't need heroes
we don't need anyone involved but also
by the way if you'd like to help us glad
to have you we're super welcoming hey
come on in right here's exactly what we
think if you have a different opinion
please share it with us and we can have
a conversation around it now i do want
to give uh credit to three specific
people because there's three different
points that i thought they brought up
really great points at one point peter
mccormick was talking to
mark cuban and mark was saying you know
hey there's not a lot of transactions
happening or whatever and peter which
you know it's kind of boss [ __ ] to say
was like well i've been to el salvador
multiple times and like here's exactly
what i saw right and then later i saw
him tweet and he had like all the
transactions there and everything and
that's the type of stuff that like in a
conversation i think is really powerful
when somebody brings theories right or
like hey this is what i think is going
to happen or or is happening and you can
show up and just say nope here's exactly
where i went here's exactly what i saw
here's exactly the transactions etc like
that type of uh
kind of discourse that is rooted in
real data or real anecdotal um kind of
environments i think is important the
second thing was uh preston pish who's
actually started the room and should get
tons of credit for for kind of kicking
this whole thing off
he kept talking about uh the macro
argument so saying listen we can talk
about like the micro situation as much
as we want in terms of where users are
utility all this stuff at some point
what happens to the corporations with
the balance sheets right at some point
what happens to the registered
investment advisors who have a bunch of
their clients sitting in cash they wake
up and they've got to move a ton of
money and they seek out this global
store of value right and i think preston
was doing a great job of that and then
actually probably the most interesting
point of the entire conversation was
lynn alden got called up on the stage
and they were talking about could the
fed and central banks around the world
actually taper could they stop with the
quantitative easing the interest rate
manipulation et cetera and lynn had a
really good point again like lynn is
very good at uh the nuance uh which was
they could do it in the short term for a
period of time but over a long period of
time structurally they really are going
to struggle to do that and i think
that's the type of stuff where when you
get into the nuance of the conversation
that's ultimately where the real value
ends up getting uh kind of um smoked out
if you will cuban has really grown on me
for
uh his thinking process in the
cryptocurrency stuff so in april i
believe it was 60 bitcoin his
cryptocurrency holdings not sure how
much that was percentage of his overall
worth but 60 bitcoin 30 i believe
ethereum then 10 awkwards right the
mavericks have um
facilitated the payment of certain
things associated with their
organization in
cryptocurrencies he's basically said
look people aren't paying in bitcoin
because they see it as a store value
people are paying in dogecoins and other
stuff like that and he expects that to
ramp up as the season ramps up but
superintendent i think he's come a
really long way when thinking about it
um he also just to people's note is he
was talking about dogecoin how he owns a
little bit and he thinks it's a good way
to basically get involved in like
learning about investing so just using
it as any asset of learning about
investing and it's better than winning
than playing the lottery or something
like that he has come a long way um i
think he's gonna continue to learn about
it and um grow along with the asset and
his thinking um and i agree with him i
believe it is a great store value i
believe the medium exchange isn't there
yet but i believe that we will get there
at some point um but the infrastructure
has to be built and the adoption has to
be there so i i got three things here
you said you preston lin and peter right
sounds like you need a fifth for that
starting five
john and i who who's got it
you can have it
maybe the coach there was other there
was other people
by the way rob dennis there's a bunch of
other people in there uh but just those
are the the moments that i remember that
kind of stuck out to me my most
memorable moment was when uh mark cuban
said to peter [ __ ] you
that was pretty funny uh but no by the
way and and part of what i like about
peter peter you're the second best
podcast host in the world but is uh he
laughs about that stuff yeah right it
was funny but and we should also say
mark not only was like one on like a
gazillion people in the twitter spaces
but i think he was doing it while he was
on like a treadmill or a stair stepper
or something and he was like out of
breath half the time and so like me
working out and also arguing with people
like 15 000 on one that was yeah that's
what i said he deserves a lot of credit
for that right but on a serious note the
one thing that i did take away from it
was the conversation between peter and
mark on a unit of exchange right and the
idea that peter came back to me said no
well mark's whole point was right this
will never be uh kind of a medium
exchange it's not going to happen all
stuff and peter was it is right people
are using it active in el salvador every
single day and uh it's legal tender and
all this stuff and he kind of dismissed
that and said it's a very small
population and all these things but i
think when you just step back for a
second and you look and you say look
like the united states uh all these you
know these bigger countries we're never
going to be the first to adopt this
stuff right it's people that have
something to lose and need a solution
for it so el salvador is a country that
can do that maybe they you know six
million people i think they have in
their country so it's very small but
we're i think they uh they legalized it
on september 7th right so we're a little
over a month old now a month and a half
old more people three to four million
people have bitcoin wallets which is
more than more people than have
traditional bank accounts in the country
right not only that from an adoption
standpoint but they've now watched their
purchasing power increased by 30 40 45
percent in the last 45 days right and
that's the first time in their life
they've seen that right so sure it's an
experiment with a smaller population uh
that that potentially has a lot to gain
and all this stuff but at the end of the
day yeah sure it's an experiment that's
going really well so no one should be
rooting for this to fail and i think
ultimately uh it's gonna be fascinating
to see if other countries see that and
adopt it and those are the things that's
going to either prove mark wrong or
right and i think uh el salvador is
something that we should be watching
closely because of that we just hit 2.5
k likes real quick i'm gonna drop in the
chat uh there is somebody i don't know
if they want me to use their name or not
so i'm not gonna say their name but
there is somebody from the audience who
watches every day they told me that they
were continuously taking notes and so
rather than just taking notes they now
are gonna tweet out various things that
are said on the show so i just dropped
the link make sure you go follow that
twitter account uh that if you don't
watch one of the episodes or something
you can always just go back and kind of
read through some of the high uh level
there so thank you
someone complimented on a tweet of mine
and said pick me for the next giveaway
in the comments i'll split the bitcoin
with you
that's not how it works
ready on the count of three i want you
to press the like button one two three
bam hit the like button
the second thing that we are going to do
in order to give away what are we going
to give away here 250 dollars worth of
bitcoin that's that 100 250 200 250.
what what do you want you you let's do
200 200 oh okay john says 200 i did 200
john's the boss whatever that's fine uh
what we're gonna do union go ahead what
we're gonna do right now is
i wanna know
who in your life have you told about the
best business show drop your twitter
account
and
who in your life have you told about the
best business show
did you tell your mom your dad your
brother your sister
your son your daughter your next-door
neighbor your side chick your mom's
brother your dad's sister your dog your
pet reptile your teacher
the guy at the grocery store did you dm
joe and tell him about the show when
he's not here who did you tell about the
best business show put it in the chat
right now
i'm used to it man you see who did you
tell about the show who did you tell
about the show
john you're picking all right
got someone 200 of bitcoin right here
live let's go
anthony
exactly what i want that's all we ask
for around here is uh just we want you
to tell everyone and anyone and i got a
bona pic with someone in the in the chat
they said the giveaway was rigged these
giveaways are not rigged we are
literally just being noted good guys
over here i don't want to hear it
listen
ladies and gentlemen in the chat
by the way there's moms that watch this
we've been told moms you too i do not
accuse you do not accuse john of rigging
the giveaways because if you accuse john
someone called me stingy and i said you
ain't winning so if it's rigged on that
note if you accuse john of rigging the
giveaways
then that means that jon won't track
down the winners and if john doesn't
track down the winners ain't nobody
getting any bitcoin around here john is
the whole key he's the linchpin he's the
leader of this
so be nice to john
because john ain't playing around all
right what i want to do is in a in a
minute here or so uh we are going to
bring on eric and james from bloomberg
these are the etf experts i had them on
the podcast earlier uh in the year
they're going to come on they're going
to explain to us the bitcoin etf why is
this important what is likely to be the
price impact once the etf gets approved
they're going to explain the difference
between the futures and the spot etf
they're going to explain the pros and
cons of the etf that's going to start
trading tomorrow this is going to be a
master class in the bitcoin etf so we're
going to go to commercial real quick i'm
going to check their audio and their
video make sure we can hear and see them
and when we come back we are going to
have a master class in bitcoin etf make
sure that you go tell your friends and
tune in
[Music]
the best business show is exactly that
it's the best why because it's the show
that me joe and john wish that we had
when we were learning
now we've got the best partner which is
sofi so far is one of those platforms
that just hits different why
sofi is basically a super app it does
everything from allowing you to have
budgeting and saving tools to helping
you refinance student loans and they
help you invest in everything from etfs
to individual stocks pre-ipo companies
and cryptocurrencies use the link below
or go to sofi.com
to sign up for a sofi active invest
account and you can win up to a thousand
dollars when you want anything to help
you create a better financial life so
far likely can do it if you're looking
for a platform where you can go and do
all in one sofa is that place we're
really excited to partner with sofi on
this because we think they've built an
amazing product and we think that the
product and features that they have will
help simplify the lives of our audience
go check them out today at sofi.com and
let us know what you think sofi.com pomp
that's where we'll be
[Music]
all right all right all right we are
back we have eric and james both from
bloomberg here with us how you guys
doing
good
awesome uh first let's just start off
with uh james uh people on the internet
think that you look like luca donek
what's up with that
i i usually get kirk cousins that's the
one i get the most from anyone
all right just making sure well
i think it was a merger of luca and um
what's his name uh the other guy
it was pretty good i mean
it was that one might be kirk cousins
awesome all right eric let's start with
you let's um talk about a etf an
exchange traded fund what exactly is the
advantage to these etfs versus let's say
uh the bitcoin trust uh that grayscale
has or some of the other uh kind of fun
structures that are in the market
generally speaking an etf is probably
the superior wrapper for just about
everything
um obviously you can do a lot on your
own if you do anything on here you can
buy the s p 500 stocks on your own you
can buy gold and store it on your own
there's nothing wrong with that uh but
you know this is a world where consumers
like convenience so
but you can log on to any exchange buy
the etf uh it has a three four letter
ticker trades on the public exchanges
it's been sort of allowed or approved by
the sec so you have that kind of comfort
um it has liquidity you can trade it
intraday
and and in this case there'll be options
on it that's very uh useful helpful so
etfs generally have just made it easy to
democratize investing gbtc
uh have done all that the problem with
gbtc is
it's not really an etf you cannot uh
you cannot create and redeem shares on
demand
which means arb is not possible and when
arb is not possible you have a price
deviating from the nav with etfs you can
create and destroy shares uh whenever
you want therefore if the price gets
away you can arb that and then the price
gets away you can orbit so there's
constant r going on keeping the price
close to the underlying uh price of what
is tracking which is what people want i
mean that's at the end of the day they
get bitcoins volatile
uh they want something that tracks the
price that's it they just that's the
bottom line and gbtc does not do that
got it and james when you think about
let's take gbtc obviously it's traded at
a massive premium at times a massive
discount is that really the big thing
that people are going to drive interest
to the etfs is the fact that the other
publicly traded vehicles right now have
those discounts and premiums and so this
won't and that four will drive some of
the inflows
yeah i think that that's definitely part
of it right now gbtc is trading at like
it's just about 18 discount to the nav
so basically what eric was talking about
in a typical etf you can exchange shares
for the underlying on a daily basis so
that means if they're the same exact
thing you can always make sure that the
price is worth exactly what it holds
with gbtc you can't do that so you can
right now the fund is closed you can't
even create shares and there is no
redeeming of shares so that whole
mechanism of being able to take the
delivery of the underlying uh just isn't
it isn't possible but again it's trading
at a discount to nav right now so uh so
if you wanted to buy gbtc and you were
expecting it to convert to an etf that
is a potential premium if you will in
the returns that you can generate but as
eric said over the short term gbtc tends
to trade very closely
to bitcoin price like over a day um it's
it's correlation it's beta to the
bitcoin market is pretty close but over
the long term it just breaks down um
because of those reasons if you bought
it at a huge premium there's times we're
trading at 120 above what it was worth
so you were buying 50 000 bitcoin when
bitcoin was actually trading at 20 000
so um that that's the problem and there
are issues with it but there are what we
can get into the nuances of it there are
also going to be some issues with the
futures etfs as well so you just kind of
need to know the issues with both and
understand the pros and cons
i want to just add the number here if
you bought gbtc last year
on this date
you would be trailing the price of
bitcoin by 160 percentage points
now there's times where you bought gbtc
and it actually outperformed bitcoin
the the problem is you don't know it's
it's got a third element and people
generally don't like the third element
that's why close end funds uh have
really not you know that's an area of
the market that's very much like gbtc
and they've been largely ignored for the
etf okay so let's talk about etfs in
general right we know gold etf gld uh
massive impact on price uh how do you
guys think about just whatever the
structure of the etf ends up being what
do we anticipate that impact to be on
the underlying uh kind of bitcoin price
if anything
i can jump in here real quick so i will
say one thing what gld did is different
from what this bitcoin etf is going to
do
if you were a retail investor you had no
real way of getting access to gold back
in the day like an etf opened up in a
completely new market right now there's
coinbase there's gemini there's ftf
everything everyone people have access
to bitcoin it's not basically
democratizing the entire space so i i
would say like equating the the impact
of the etf on the gold market to the
uh bitcoin market is probably a little
far-fetched it's a little bit much
again this is also futures but it's
definitely no matter what people say
people say it's like fake and paper
bitcoin but really it it is you're
buying bitcoin so any buying of this is
going to be um more demand on the actual
underlying bitcoin market in some way
and we can talk about margin
requirements for futures but the the
answer is that it's going to be positive
but it's not likely to be positive with
new demand into the etf but it's not
going to be
the same impact that we saw with gold
and also gold that was one of the
biggest best runs for gold that had it
launched right before uh not long before
the 2008 financial crash like there was
a whole bunch of other situations going
on there with with gold yeah and i also
think there's a lot of optimism baked
into the uh run in bitcoin that we've
seen so while
a bitcoin futures etf in particular
because that isn't even like gld that's
more like uso and we know from history
that things that track futures in the
etf market are largely generally ignored
by advisors which have
24 trillion in assets that's the real
giant pool of money that ets tend to tap
into the most um but there's traders and
i think uh uso has attracted traders
this will attract traders but i think
the bigger issue here and i think you
know
we don't think they'll be uh this won't
be like some game changer i just heard i
saw a call that somebody from um
i won't say who it is but they thought
that this etf where the bitcoin futures
were taking 36 billion in flows in the
first year um that seems very uh overly
optimistic i would say more like four or
five now if it was etf tracking spot
bitcoin uh maybe we'd get to 30 billion
um you know given what we saw at gbtc
and up in canada but
i i still think for the futures one the
big news here
is that a it gives traders something to
use um it will be used by traders don't
it definitely will uh but it's what it
represents is this slow start to the sec
getting comfortable with bitcoin and
crypto you could see ether you could see
the physical you could see people who
have active funds that do crypto picking
inside an etf like an arc down the road
we go and all of a sudden now you're
talking about real assets but this
particular launch probably isn't going
to be like some big game changer asset
wise so that's definitely the takeaway
that i've had from conversations with
various people in the market is uh it
this is more of a signal and a really
positive step forward but the actual
price impact may not be massive as
people want talk to me about what
happened in canada so these were spot
etfs uh related to bitcoin and i
remember i actually can't remember which
one of the two of you but you guys were
going nuts it was like your super bowl
those two the two days uh that those
started to trade because it was just
massive inflows and it was like every
day they were breaking a new record so
like what was going on there
well it was
the the what was so fascinating about
those and i'll let james jump in because
he's done a lot of work on this but i'll
just say what what caught my attention
is that
the trading the volume on this etf
was like it made it the number one or
number two most traded etf in canada on
day one
and then day two and then day three i
mean it didn't go away there wasn't that
initial pop it kept the volume going and
it's still i think today a top 10 traded
etf
that was shocking to me uh that it would
get that much attention so quickly the
flows did come i think it had like a i
don't know two months straight flow
streak and then the flows came out but
now you know there's a lot of products
up there that the market's definitely
opened up but it was those early numbers
that blew my mind it was something like
it traded the equivalent
of like what tesla trades in the us
on day one
if you account for the size of the
market if you if you translate the size
of the market canada is 27 smaller uh
than we are
uh so if you do that conversion which is
a little loose but you know there's
something to be said about if you can do
that much in canada that speaks uh well
to what you could do in the us but i'll
let james take over about the
growth after that yeah i would say i
would also say like so um i would also
jump in and say part of that i think is
was demand from the u.s and around the
world because as we mentioned an etf is
a superior wrapper um it just makes it
can you can put anything in etf we talk
about this all the time people have been
complaining about high yield bonds being
an etf forever but it just makes the the
process of trading and holding these
things super efficient but i think part
of the the thing is um as we saw when
these things launched is when gbtc
really started going into a discount
there's there just became a lot more
options so while a retail investor in
the u.s couldn't go out and buy these
etfs in canada
institutions probably could that had
money in gbtc so they might have traded
out and gone here because it's just a
more efficient vehicle um so we think i
like we talked about the massive demand
i think that showed more that it wasn't
just canada that was accessing these
these products so people were going
there and that happens in the us a lot
the u.s we basically outsource liquidity
um people from all over the world
institutions they could be in asia
anywhere they come to the u.s to trade
in our etf market because we are so
liquid and that is very important to
institutions
so i think that kind of happened with
candidates etf launch
if beto that pro shares etf or whichever
one becomes the liquid one
and it starts trading say 100 million
200 million a billion a day
all of a sudden you're gonna get people
from all over the world using it um
you'll have a japan pension fund using
it to maybe get some uh quick access to
bitcoin so that is correct uh the u.s
market is so liquid and no other
countries can really produce that kind
of liquidity so we will steal
investors from the whole world into this
fund again i think a futures fund won't
steal as much as say a spot physical
will but that's a very good point and
the thing there though is there's only
like one or two of those per category
that get that liquid that they start to
get used by everybody and then once they
get like used by everybody they become
so liquid they almost are unstoppable
and that's sort of what spy is uh eem
you know there's a couple we call them
liquidity kings and once you get to that
spot um that's something you can't buy i
mean even you assets can be kind of
bought in a way like you could bring
assets over but liquidity has to grow
naturally and when it does it's very
attractive to people talk to us about
the difference between the bitcoin spot
etf and the bitcoin futures etf i know
that there's a ton of debate as to
whether the spot etf should have gotten
approved first or the futures we get the
future so what is the key differences
between those two structures
yeah i could start so i'll say like as
we talk about this the big the big thing
here is it's a move from zero to one so
like while we are we think the spot the
product would be better for retail
investors probably um just because it's
less confusing
as we mentioned this is zero to one for
the sec which is a big move but it's not
necessarily going to have a massive
impact the other thing that i wanted to
go back to was eric talked about 24
trillion investor in advisor assets um i
mean even if you take a tiny tiny sliver
of that that's a lot of money that's
going into bitcoin whether it's the
futures etf or the spot etf
but the big difference here is futures
you have to roll every month so if
you're holding the front month contract
right that expires so the next one
expires on october 29th you need to sell
that contract that's going to expire on
october 29th and buy the next contract
that is november which is
november 30th whatever whenever the
contract ends so basically what happens
is in a typical market like with oil and
other thing there's storage costs so
that next contract is usually more
expensive that's called contango so what
you're doing is you're selling the lower
price contract and buying the higher
price so every time you're losing a tiny
bit of money and that can add up over
the last year that was about 36 percent
um so i mean it's it's not nothing um
but we think we expect that to go down
and eric and i actually had a call this
morning with mike mcglone who's some
people on here probably know he's um our
commodity analyst and he covers bitcoin
as well and he thinks that's going to go
way down so right now there's times
where contango is acting more like
a commodity that's hard to store like
oil and something like that that it's
hard to get this arbitrage because what
you can do is it's called a cash and
carry trade you essentially are going to
buy spot and sell the futures and
essentially you can earn that difference
when the the futures contract that's
coming up is more expensive
but right it's not that expensive to
store bitcoin and get bitcoin like it is
to go store barrels of oil um so we
think it's just going to be armed away
eventually um which but even still i
mean right now we're talking about 10 to
12 on average the last year or two i
think um but mike mcglone thinks it
could go down to half that five to six
percent which again isn't perfect
obviously a spot bitcoin etf doesn't
have any of those roll costs but for
five to six percent um for some of these
people who are going to be using these
products especially traders um in any
long along that lines um it's not that
big of a deal probably
and and let me a couple points here so
if you look at the pro funds mutual fund
that tracks bitcoin futures it's
basically the prequel to beto it's
already been out two and a half months
it's given us a nice case study for what
veto will do
it's only missed bitcoin by about 1 60
basis points in two and a half months
that's very good it's way better than we
thought it sort of feeds into mcglone's
prediction that the role was only bad
going way back and that going forward
especially with the incentive to arb and
how the etf will bring all this money in
uh we're looking at it's probably more
optimistic than we originally thought
and i but still let's say it's five
percent a year if something costs you
five percent here that's kind of an
annoying high fee the other thing is
advisors
who you know it's possible if this thing
tracks really well
over long periods it could bring in some
of those advisors but remember they're
once bitten twice shy a lot of advisors
bought vxx and learned the hard way what
role costs are that's like 40 a year vxx
is brutal uh uso could be 20 a year so
they probably are ung there's a couple
of them where they probably learned the
hard way that anything that rolls
futures is is could really um you could
get the bet right you could actually bet
right on oil or natural gas and actually
not win because of the product you chose
that's a big reputational sort of thing
that these etfs will have to overcome
that said the ability to track bitcoin
on a daily and weekly basis is all that
will matter
to the trading crowd and that's a real
audience and that's fine there are etfs
that are for traders and some that are
for long term
the question is can this one actually
build its audience beyond the trading
crowd and that roll cost will be a big
uh you know variable in that
when you guys think about the grayscale
uh bitcoin trust gbtc uh it now has been
confirmed that they're going to apply to
have it converted to the spot etf do we
think that uh just odds have increased
now because features have been approved
but we don't know much more than that or
do you guys have other thoughts around
uh that application and the potential
for it to be approved
okay i'll go uh so i i think what as i
mentioned this is zero to one for the
sec right so this is them and and as
people have talked about i mean a lot of
people out there um they talk about uh
no need for an etf uh their people are
mad at gensler because of he's so
negative towards crypto but honestly he
knows his stuff like as much as people
want to say that he doesn't he really
does know his stuff and he's learning
and i i really think that as we
mentioned i think the spot product is a
better product for most people that want
to use this i think they should have
allowed both at the same time
and let investors put their money where
they want to put their money right let
them democrat let democracy pick the the
winning structure uh but for whatever
reason genzler chose this he uh he
highlights a few things so one of the
things is these futures products are
under something called the 1940 act and
we don't need to get the nitty-gritty
here but like essentially it's a little
bit there's a little more consumer
investor protections there's a little
more restrictions on what you can and
can't do
versus something under the 1933 act
which is an older act that gbtc if it
converts and these other spot products
which we have a bunch of filings out for
uh they would fall into that 1933 act so
that's a big difference but again i
think the the part of the reason that
gensler went with this first is one
there's obviously some animosity in
congress janet yellen doesn't like
bitcoin from
everything we've seen so i think this is
almost like uh cyoa like a little bit of
gensler covering himself because he can
say hey we slowed the roll uh we went
with futures which are already on a
regulated market by the cftc um i didn't
allow it right away we're taking our
time so i think this is just him like if
anything goes wrong he has all these
cushions between him uh whether bitcoin
gets cut 70 people lose their money
which obviously is possible to happen
we've seen it happen plenty of times so
i think there's a whole bunch of reasons
why we went this route but i do think
we're going to see a conversion at some
point i just don't know if it's going to
be on gbc's first try and a little bit
of background so van neck is they filed
for this so the whole process for those
1940 etfs was a whole different scenario
which is why a lot of people weren't
with eric and i when we were calling for
an october approval initially because
they go through a different process
where it's just a 75-day period gbtc and
these other physical etfs they go
through a separate process there's
something called a 19b4 application they
basically need to apply to the exchange
and ask for a rule change to allow these
etfs to trade um
so that process
that's where you're used to hearing all
this like delay or deny or approve and
all the other filings we've seen they
either delayed or approved so they go
45-day process delay or
delay or approve delay or approve and it
adds up to 240 days and that's after
they get this 19b4 application to hit
the what's called the sec register so
bitwise filed one on friday and it
hasn't hit the register yet but after it
hits that register then you have
basically 240 days uh before the sec
needs to make a decision um and we have
vanx spot etf that they filed through
the 1933 act on that 19b4 process and
their final date of approval from filing
on december 30th of 20 i think around
december 35 know the exact date 2020 is
november 11th so it's a long time before
they can be approved so even if gb2c
applies for this application it's not
that 75-day process i believe it's going
to be that 240-day post-19 before
process so it's going to be a long time
even if they get approved the first time
and we don't think any of these etfs
that are coming up on this approval
window in this quarter are going to get
approved by the sec because they were
very very explicit in wanting a 1940x
product that only holds futures yeah
let me um let me jump in here because
yes it's a different process it takes
longer the heart of the matter though is
the problem for gbtc converting is it
would have to convert to a 33 act fund
and gensler does not like that act he is
really not into it he likes the 40 act
it has a a myriad of more investor
protection so as james said it's it's a
cya kind of act
he feels much more comfortable with it
so the question you have to ask yourself
yes there's all these other technical
delays whatever but is when will gary
gensler get comfortable with the 33 act
or is it possible somehow bitcoin is
denoted as security because that means
it could then go under the 40 act
because you have to be a security to get
under that act so which of those two
things happened i i just don't see
either of those things happening in any
in the near term even with and then you
add on the other delays i just i don't
know i
i feel like
um you're gonna hear a lot of
talk about a conversion but
the question if you hear anybody say
this in your show
ask them well do you are you saying that
gary gensler is now comfortable with the
1933 act that's the question they won't
be able to answer
all right so i have two questions i got
my brother should they got questions for
you guys too first one uh james you said
uh when we called for it in october you
guys were right are you guys taking a
little victory lap here are we getting a
little dancing on graves
yeah we i i i did i have a bunch of
those remind me of this in seven days
and 10 days oh my god people were saying
us were idiots for calling for this so
i'm waiting for those notifications to
pop up and just go back i like the
tweet i mean um look uh we felt we had
an opportunity here because
most people did not agree with us
we felt strongly and that's a good time
to sort of put yourself out there
because if you're right it's a big it's
a big payoff reputationally but you know
two things one is um we did get four
things right we got the fact they'd
approve the first one out pro shares the
date
we missed by one day okay fine we said
that's fair enough and then the fact
that they wouldn't approve many at once
some people were replying with that and
i was trying to say i think they should
do it but here's what we think they will
do so
uh it would yes i agree i took a tiny
victory lap uh today but you know i i
don't want to get too into it because
honestly what what it really came back
to you ever see silence the lambs when
um hannibal lecter tells agent starling
just look at the case file
it really came down to genzler's words
he basically was like look
um i want to see 40x etfs that hold
futures i look forward to reviewing them
that was the heart of the case
and ultimately i think it proved to be
true there was some other evidence
around that but it wasn't that hard to
predict to be honest i think people got
caught up in recency bias they were used
to the sec you know their hopes were
built up and the sec dashed them like
lucy pulling the football away and i
understand that but in this case there
were many different situations and
variables that led us to uh come out
with that call uh which um obviously
came true but we were nervous at times
there was a couple times where like uh
that that little thing over there that
could be bad news and we were used to
getting the football pulled away but um
in the in this case it it worked out so
my second question is do you guys have a
prediction for when the spot etf gets
approved do we have like a month
where we think that's going to happen
i'll go all right so i'll say to two
things one i'm a little more positive on
this than eric is because he's saying
the 1933 act again i think that was more
uh gensler covering himself and slowing
things down allowing like kind of things
to happen a little slowly i don't think
he really has that big of a problem with
the 33 act i think he might just be
leaning out as a crutch because as you
talk about gld falls under that 33 act
it's also a grantor trust which is the
same structure as gbtc so there's plenty
of these products already out in in the
system so i think eventually he'll get
comfortable then i think i think we see
one approved in 2022 um
that's why i guess
i'll say q4 i'll give it uh i'll give it
a year from from now
yeah a year a year from launch i think
yeah so he's he's going q4 2022. i'd
probably land there if i was vegas and
forced to make a book i'd probably start
the over under november december 2022
which is about a year um but anything's
possible um again
i don't know what would happen though to
get genzer comfortable the 33 act i
haven't really been able to make that
connection so i'm not ready to go on the
record and be as out there
with that call yet as i was with this
one because i haven't connected the dots
in what would make genzler come around
and until i do i'm not really gonna say
much more than just gun to head okay
fine maybe a year all right what do you
guys got
uh i'll go first thanks for doing this
guys um so my question would be we
talked about kind of the differences
between uh futures in a spot etf
relative to institutions traders uh
retail investors etc and it sounds like
in my opinion and you guys as well that
this may be you know opening up the door
and getting people more comfortable uh
with the spot etf if we were to get a
structure like that whether it's you
know next year the following year etc is
there any estimates uh that you guys
have seen or you guys are familiar with
on kind of how much inflow that could
bring into the market
uh a lot uh that would be that look this
is the holy grail a spot bitcoin etf and
then a spot ether etf
and then uh you know a spot etf where
kathy wood picks the crypto she likes
this is a big deal this would be in our
estimate possibly a hundred billion
dollar category
um after you know four or five years
now you know inflation obviously helps a
little bit the price of bitcoin would
obviously
depend on that but i see uh a torrent of
flows into this um especially also as
the vanguard effect kicks in what you'll
find is that someone will come in like
uh i don't know a state's trade and
they'll undercut on fees so we could be
looking at a world in five years where i
don't think it'll be for vanguard let's
just say a vanguard-esque total crypto
market etf for like
15 basis points
and that will sell
in in a big way and in a deep way um
we've seen it happen in the stock market
and the bond market with etf so there's
no reason to think that after a lot of
that
clutter
gets gets put out there you know a lot
of product gets put out there they get
cheaper they get liquid you couldn't see
you know something close to 100 billion
uh after five years or so
john yeah and uh i'll i'll go real quick
and say that there's about nine billion
in etf's bitcoin etfs globally more if
you include the other ets so um
that it's it's not like it's a massive
thing but the us is the largest market
the other thing i'd say you everyone
likes to talk about trying to value
bitcoin based on the gold market
different things as eric mentions 24
trillion dollars in advisor assets a lot
of people talk about putting like one to
five percent of their portfolio and
bitcoin at this point even if it's one
percent or 0.01 percent of that 24
trillion dollars we're talking hundreds
of millions of dollars that would flow
in so um that could some of that could
be through the futures of some of it
could be through spot etf that
eventually gets lodged but it's a whole
massive pool of capital that uh could
enter this uh via this way easier than
going through like
a crypto account specifically
yeah talking about that pool capital
thanks for joining us guys um what is
going to be the inflow for this etf for
this future gtf now and are you guys
going to put any money into it
uh
um look so i don't actually invest in in
etfs um i just don't want to have
anything in my head that makes me biased
so um
just in full disclosure i own like a
couple index funds and schwab etfs but
they're like the boring vanilla stuff
believe me it kills me sometimes not to
buy etfs like i really wanted to buy the
uranium etf a couple years ago i nailed
that call but i didn't and so i
generally just sort of stay away from it
to be a sort of unbiased analyst that
said
i think look i think the futures etfs
could see four to five billion in the
first year and i think the majority of
that will go to the one that gets the
liquidity so like let's say vito comes
out and it becomes eighty percent of the
liquidity i think it could get seventy
eighty percent of the assets but then
remember let's say arc arc is going to
put out a futures etf they'll get by the
eighth to market that's not a good place
to be but that's kathy wood she has a
lot of name power uh people uh you know
a lot of younger people who are into
crypto are like her too so she could
actually give this like sort of second
wind uh then you have bitwise you have
all these people that have built-in
markets so while i think a lot of the
spoils will go to the real liquid one
that is out first
i do think there is a lot of uh to be
said for some of the ones coming in
later
that said i don't see this as the big
sort of watershed moment that a physical
would be so i'll stick to five billion
after one year
uh i don't know if james is uh coming
over or under on that but i imagine
under a little i'm probably under a
little but i guess it depends on how the
roll costs play out i will say though
it's grayscale while it's basically at
40 billion in aum right now 39 ish um it
it's only had like seven billion of
inflows in its entire life since like
2013 or 2014 or whatever it is so a lot
of that is appreciation so if bitcoin
doubles from here i mean those numbers
could go way up so it's it's hard to say
where the ass is going to be but uh i
think four billion is a fair guess i'd
probably put the over under there um
yeah
i'm going and i'm going 10 billion
and it has nothing to do with inflows
it's all price appreciated
at some point like you know it hits 10
billion it's a big variable
yeah uh let me ask this question if you
guys were evaluating uh the etf that
started trading
can i get one caveat here yes
okay there is one thing to watch which
is
the front month futures market isn't
that big so let's say four or five
billion came in
uh some of these etfs might hit position
limits
i i'll say for now it probably won't
be a big deal but let let's just say
they become too popular you know they
get four or five six billion
um they may have to start owning other
parts of the curve that will dilute
their ability to track spot
and that's what happened with uso and
when that happened the trading crowd
just hated it they fleed uso and they
have not come back xiv or svxy there are
some exotic etfs when they cut that
sensitivity
um it doesn't work out well so this is
just one thing to watch
is they could it's possible to become a
little too popular for their own good
and that that could alter the dynamics
of this i just want to throw that out
there okay when you guys are evaluating
the futures etf that's going to start
trading tomorrow it looks like um walk
us through the pros and cons and then
should retail be more interested in this
or is this more of like an institutional
or ria type product like just somebody
sits down they say okay this is going to
start trading how should i evaluate it
and where do i come out on pros and cons
of this specific vehicle
i'll i'll jump in real quick so the one
thing we keep talking about the trading
crowd i mean if you're using an
over-the-counter retail account with one
of these other providers i mean the fees
are not cheap i mean compared to zero
trading fees and ridiculously tight
spreads that you're going to get in this
etf it definitely makes it cheaper so
again if you're trading this is actually
not a bad way to get exposure especially
you're going in and out um because
there's no transaction fees in the
spread and the spreads are tighter um so
that that's the first thing and then the
other thing is you're basically
comparing at this point it would be the
futures etf to gbtc as far as i'm
concerned and you need to understand the
pros and cons of both uh gbtc might not
track as well especially with the
discounts lately it's been moving
exactly in line uh ever since it's got
to this discount level it just kind of
moves with bitcoin but that's not
guaranteed like it's probably going to
be way closer with the the etf but again
you're buying at a discount so right now
it's trading at 18
so all of a sudden if the etf does get
approved or gbc can convert that's a
whole 18 or it's like a at 18 it's like
24 that goes up to me to meet nav so
there's that positive but again over a
shorter term you're not you're not
tracking that closely and especially you
don't know what bitcoin's price is going
to do over that time so even if for some
reason bitcoin goes into one of its bear
markets and you're holding even if it
comes back to nav it was still a bad
purchase at that point so again i think
the the futures etf is good for trading
it should be uh much closer to spot as
eric mentioned as long as we don't hit
those futures limits those position
limits um so you just have to weigh the
pros and cons i think a spot bitcoin etf
would be best for everyone but that's
not an option yeah the
the retail yolo zoomer crowd
i think is going to take to this
especially because they can now buy call
options on it
i mean this is going to get real because
they can't really do that right now
right so the options market around the
one that becomes the liquid one real
demand from retail traders i will say
advisors and long-term retail investors
probably aren't going to flock to this
but retail traders who just like juice
they like the mean stocks this should be
right up their alley given how easy and
cheap it will be to trade and the
options on it so i can see that whole
crowd coming in and then i can see as it
gets more liquid the bigger institutions
using it for like uh you know
operational purposes and uh hedging and
things like that um that but you know
so i guess that that's my answer i just
would warn any retail investor just
you know this is a trading tool i
wouldn't i wouldn't buy and hold it
unless unless you get some evidence that
the roll costs aren't that bad
all right my last question we have any
uh end of year bitcoin price predictions
where do we think bitcoin itself ends
up you can go first eric
[Laughter]
look i i've been watching bitcoin it
looked like when elon and cassie and
jack dorsey did that that you know that
uh panel looks like it rebounded there
and then it got some lift from the
etf news and some other things it's been
on a nice run i mean
i don't know like is a lot of this baked
in so i
it's tough i can't make predictions but
i'd say
um you're talking end of the year yes um
yeah maybe there's some some by the news
or uh buy the room or sell the news for
a month or two and then maybe there's
some more bullish news but or maybe this
is just all very bullish and it's
actually just unleashing a whole new
wave of this bull market
um i i i just don't know um i can see
this going either way so what's the
price right now
62 000 okay knowing i never i'm not
allowed to make predictions i'll say 70.
yeah
we're not allowed we're technically not
allowed i have no idea yeah i'm not
that's not my forte
yeah i i would say no predictions not
bitcoin not not price predictions yeah i
would say i i so i'd say a lot of the
on-chain metrics that like i've been
following but there's plenty of people
on twitter are like very bullish
obviously right now long-term holder
percentages and all those things um but
again i the one thing i'd be worried
about is buy the rumor sell the news
type situation especially after this
thing starts trading so
yeah that's that's the thing i'd be
watching but there's a lot of certainly
bullish indicators right now but bitcoin
surprises everyone on a regular basis so
there's one thing to be to be said here
about
the more the etf the more
you know pro shares has all these sales
people they go golfing with advisors
they know they just have built they have
audiences that they're friends with
so the the more this the more people
have these etfs van eck has one and then
it's um you know you're looking at just
really tapping into a whole army of
sales people
and distributors and distribution
um and i think that's worth something
that's why
i don't know if this is just a quick hit
by the news sell the rumor but possibly
some of that but i will say that that's
why i think this is a much bigger deal
than even the people who are a little
like i don't know
uh negative on the futures element the
roll cost
this really is a major
uh situation because of of what it's
tapping into and what it is sort of like
putting into motion which is all of
these big asset managers have all of
these sales people
and they're gonna start calling people
about this and going you know and
talking about it and those people a lot
of those advisors in particular over
time might you know might be comfortable
buying some but um like i said a
physical one would be better for this
yeah i'll jump in and say there's plenty
of people out there that think that
there's no need for an etf it's us we
don't need it we don't want it uh tyrone
ross over at onramp i've been on panels
with him debating this he's he's against
an atm
he's not a fan but the one thing i would
say is if you're an advisor and you're
just going to put one percent of your
clients account in your two percent um
what's easier just buying this etf and
just putting that in this on the
financial rails that you already have on
your system or you're going to go out
and create accounts with all these other
crypto providers to put like
a little bit of your clients money into
these accounts and track it in different
areas which again on-ramp is trying to
make easier but i think there's just
plenty of people that are at these big
shops that have these old massive legacy
financial systems and putting an etf in
this position just opens up to a giant
new pool of capital going back to that
so that's the huge indicator it's going
to democratize some people's exact
access to bitcoin in the same way we
talk about gold it's just not as bad
because people can get it regularly on
their own but there's plenty of advisors
out there that aren't weren't going to
touch bitcoin until it's in etf yeah
it's not it's not the it's not veto
itself it's that veto is just
is a first step yeah i think that's the
general takeaway here i'm not buying the
futures etf unless proshare sends a
salesperson to take me golfing that's
right that's my takeaway from this
conversation right
they will they will
that could be i'm sure there's somebody
that they'll send i'm gonna need a vest
and some lunch today
awesome all right guys listen thank you
so much for uh for taking the time to do
this you guys have been all over it uh
this is your virtual victory lap from us
to you guys uh you nailed it so uh
thanks so much for all the hard work
anyone who uh who's not following both
of these guys on twitter definitely go
follow them uh and then james but also
by the way i'm not gonna let you out of
here before uh he did the podcast in one
february i think and i thought i was
following him and i re i recently
realized i wasn't i follow him and then
he tweets out and he's like hey this guy
took six months to follow yeah
big time
uh
i had to call you out
awesome guys listen thank you so much
for doing this we'll do it again in the
future and uh i think a lot of people
are hoping you guys are right in terms
of uh inflows to the etfs
thank you all right see you guys thanks
paul bye
are either one of you guys buying the
etf nope
the futures yeah no i'm not even buying
the spot etf no no no you just buy the
real thing yeah you're like a purist i
mean if you're a retail investor you do
what you want but i think you should
just own the real asset
john
i'm not buying the futures you're gonna
buy the spot etf probably won't buy the
spot either if it wasn't approved i
would say the difference is if it's a
vehicle like uh like if you have a
retirement account that you can't own
actual bitcoin in then the etf is good i
got some gbtc in my retirement account
yeah i got some gbtc too yeah gbtc has
been popular i'm a little i'm a little
disappointed at how much the premium and
the discount moves around but from when
i you know just wait till it gets
converted we'll be all right yeah
hopefully they convert it well with
cinema retirement they're saying i got
30 years before i can get it out my
whole thing with gbtc is right oh you
know they're saying yeah it's at a it's
at a big discount
a while ago or even higher uh but my
whole thing is like when they see the
the the reduction in fees that they may
get from converting it to etf we'll see
if they continue to do that all right we
just crossed over 3
000 likes great work everyone great work
big show today we appreciate you all
coming here to watch that's why we
continue to just hand you bitcoin what
we're going to do now is we're going to
pick two people two winners each one
gets a hundred bucks of bitcoin to wrap
up the show we appreciate you guys
coming here every single day and
watching we will build the biggest
business show in the world as long as
you keep showing up and pressing that
like button we'll keep bringing free
content education knowledge a couple of
laughs maybe we'll even be nice to each
other on occasion so what i need you to
do is in the chat i want you to leave
a comment
i need your twitter account
and i need you
to tell us what's the one thing you
learned today what'd you learn today
leave your twitter account we're going
to pick two people right now john's
going to pick one person i'm going to
pick one person what did you learn today
and your twitter account in the chat
we're going to pick two are we going to
comment on everyone and you each get
hundred bucks that price prediction he's
like you go first
well they're not allowed to that's why
yeah yeah
so that's all right all right come on
let's go leave in the chat
what did you learn today what's your
twitter account we're gonna pick two
people
john you got somebody yet no dude
they're just flying yeah just give it a
second
man
you got somebody yet yeah okay say your
person
oh wait i can't pick that person there
he won once
so
but somebody did say that ranger
nakamoto be biting people that's what
they learned today
ranger's good he's just prepping for the
bull run
um all right you know what i saw i saw
uh
some people were commenting saying that
they just found the show and stuff and
they're really enjoying it so i
appreciate that all right i got mine
john palapil
i may be saying that wrong you win he
said you know what i learned today stack
sats that's what he learned stack set
that's a great lesson very simple very
easy stack sats i love it john you win
100 bucks at bitcoin we got your twitter
account john will all right coordination
no john no john is picking john is
picking up john's got a second one i
mean no no go john go go go ahead greg
doyle
congrats greg sorry i almost ruined your
giveaway there
greg said gbtc is undervalued
discount hey all right what are you
gonna say joe greg greg congratulations
congratulations everyone we appreciate
you all congratulations good name by the
way come back tomorrow maybe we'll give
you some tomorrow maybe we'll do bigger
giveaways we'll see we got by the way
should i tell them who the guests are
this week coming
yeah we got some big guests coming in
tell them
i'm gonna hold on to it we got two
different days where we got real big
guests coming it's all right you come
back you'll learn you'll learn to just
show up and we'll take care of you guys
what are you going to say joe before
everybody go
before classes dismissed i forgot you
forgot yeah
i just wanted to tell you you're doing a
great job we john and i appreciate all
your hard work he must have got the
letter from the union
tell them strike was about to start you
guys gonna write me a letter no we had
sent letters yeah i got a few people in
my dms in the chat asking they're like
so what do we do yeah oh by the way the
union's approximately up to about 40
members now so oh you guys got 40
growing by the day and growing by the
day oh so what i was going to say by the
way is earlier for the people that
watched last week we all made
predictions on where we thought bitcoin
would be on monday
john uh made me realize earlier in the
show that i was the closest it was
closest so what'd you say i doesn't
really matter i beat both of y'all yeah
well i want to verify what did you say
well you said whatever he said plus one
dollar yeah that's true okay so what do
you say y'all said that we were going to
hit all-time highs
okay and you said no and i said
underneath i said you got in my head
that's the problem i said 63 i would
have won but you got my head i raised it
by like seven so the prediction now is
since i was right about the first one
y'all could trust me now
48 hours we're gonna be uh 100 of people
that bought bitcoin and held until now
we'll be in the profit
are you doing short-term directional
advice for this all right we gotta go
no this is financial advice
if i get a letter by the way i'm just
gonna put out this warning one time
there's still people watching ready
if you join the union you will never win
a giveaway
that's not true john and i are the ones
always picking too smartly
guess what the funds are only flowing
from one wallet not true
oh that is not true damn all right don't
join the union let me tell you don't
join the can i'm gonna counter protest
the union do whatever you want
unions open
[Laughter]
taking applications all right
sofi.com by 8 pm today you got to have
your account open you got to have 2 000
in there to join the diamond hands club
thursday night we will do our very first
q a
virtual session whatever you want to
call it diamond hands club
on thursday night what that means is you
open account you put two thousand
dollars in there you're in the diamond
hands club we then will get you you'll
come on to zoom and we'll answer your
questions about investing certified.com
make sure you read the terms and
conditions what people calling you bezos
in the chat trying to break up our union
was he successful i don't know but i
guess well he he held the one vote and
then they're like we got a revoked
because there was some shenanigans there
there was like sure
going around
apparently telling people you joined the
union you're getting fired
i don't know what they were doing but
all i know is that you two running the
vote it's definitely rigged let's just
make one thing clear i'm not gonna say
this is gonna happen but i i strongly
advise that it may happen if you join
the union your percentage chance of
winning a giveaway goes up
all right thanks all everyone for
watching we appreciate y'all ain't
nobody starting the union hope you have
a wonderful monday oh today's 18th the
18th that's
what are you wearing for halloween what
are you dressing up as
himself he's fly
um knocking off your credit card today's
today's my day to pay it off so
reminding myself right now
we'll see you guys tomorrow thanks so
much make sure you like the video make
sure you subscribe to the channel to the
moon
[Music]
you